[Music]
citizens of the reject Nation it's me
Teran this guy Andrew flash cord I got
Halloween nails and a Halloween shirt on
but we're not watching a Halloween movie
Are We nope sure not 21 Jump Street I
wish that you would have jumped and then
I could show a street we can't do that
here we can't we can't we just don't
have time listen you guys got to leave a
like even though this intro it's lacking
you got to leave a comment you got say
listen terara get with it be better I
agree okay and you also have to ring the
bell ring the bell thanks to prepper for
helping us edit down these highlights
and if you haven't joined patreon we
call you super sexy over there so get
over there now you can sneak up with
your own copy and also don't forget that
Greg and John offer exclusive highlights
and watch alongs over there on the
patreon or we also call you again I'll
say it super sexy we're in it now I
think I'm ready are you ready to watch
21 Jump
Street let's do
it may I have your
pleas may I have your ATT please I feel
like this song was also released in 2005
and this is the Year 2005 probably like
right I feel like probably I don't know
music like I know films but you're
probably right I think it was around
there
oh the braces known each other for a
really long time and
uh live across the street from each
other and stuff and uh me on every first
date you're not asking me to prom are
youh [__] no no I I I I don't know how
to put this nicely I that was nice I
thought just straight to the point yeah
I've heard way worse to me right if you
didn't get your grades up you weren't
going to the prom but I'm I'm going to
be prom King I'm glad you had a great
time in school cuz you ain't learned
nothing at least you remembered at prom
there's a king I mean that he did learn
something yeah and he learned how to
kick a trash can I yeah he's doing all
right yeah is he going to pick it up oh
ow you can't teach that in acting how to
no how to kick a trash kick a trash can
like awkwardly like that only Jonah Hill
could pull that
off
oh we meet again Slim Shady what's up
holy [__] how do you recognize him
without his braces just cuz he still
looks nerdy he just he just screams
nerd such [__] dang is he going to
help him study and he's going to help
him do the physical stuff oh 100a yeah
he's got the brains and he's got the the
Hot
Tots
[Music]
has
I would love to be a person on one of
those popups for the training academy I
just think it'd be fun maybe get my name
out there a little bit more hey see Min
is improved that's it's all about
improvements I present to you the
graduates of class
137 you're ready for a lifetime of being
badass mother yeah heck yeah that was a
lot faster than I was expecting to be
with the get right in there yeah they're
like that's great set you up for that
you guys really think there a police
matter to get your frisbee back get your
own [__]
frisbee
oh
[__] yours isn't loaded right huh no
we're supposed to unload him first right
you no that's that's no fun come
on this guy like big time drug dealers
if we could take them down as our first
bus we'd be off Park Duty for
sure you see what I see Cannabis sativa
all right this is how you know was at
least 10 15 years ago cuz right now this
would not be a big deal at all in fact
the cops be like can we can we take a
few
pups have we forgotten that the use of
marijuana is illegal man you guys even
real cops you look like the kids on the
Halloween is called M EA that is my
dream to eat straight up peanut butter
with a fork oh damn what I chase someone
Chase someone are you leaving your bike
here all right
on the
bike it's classic I'm going shoot you if
you don't slow down man come
on the editing this really helps to play
with like the the bait and like the
punch line it's great it's going to say
dude you're probably faster without the
bike that's it come
here damn it's going to charge you dude
you got to read a Miranda rights problem
is if you don't read Miranda rights you
you can't arrest
them
yeah these guys are not by the book
[__] oh boy as we can see
stated right there the department was
forced to drop the charges because you
forgot to read him his Miranda right ah
you called it I'm not even a cop I knew
that yeah that's the basic thing do you
even know the Miranda recognize that
actor oh yeah I mean Bill Last of Us oh
yeah of course but also um so many other
things oh yeah yeah go ahead it's four
declamatory sentences followed by a
question for a total of 57 words it it I
think it sounds something like uh you
are under arrest you have the right to
remain silent you oh right you have the
right to remain an attorney did you say
that you have the right to be an
attorney you do have the right to be an
attorney if you want
to where were you I was chasing my Pur
honestly he did get away that my
elbow yeah we're Reviving a canceled
under under cover police program from
the 80s and revamping it for modern
times so all they do now is recycle [__]
from the past and expect us all not to
notice these programs involves the use
of young immature seing officers you're
going to send us into like a child sex
slavery ring or something whoa that's
heavy and deep yeah that's great uh
where should we report to down on Jump
Street 37 Jump Street 37 37 right oh
it's
21 I think it's uh you under arrest you
have the right for anything you say can
will be used against you in a court of
law you have the right to an attorney
you cannot afford an attorney one will
be one will be given to you thank you
RoboCop all the old Misfits in a
church hey it the cube cool I didn't
know he's in this get your mothering ass
up when I'm talking you will be going
undercover as high school students hey
cool this is giving me a Never Been
Kissed Vibe yeah cops edition Justus
Beaver Molly Cyrus looking
[__] angry black Captain it ain't
nothing but a stupid
stereotype I'm black and I work my ass
off to be the captain and sometimes I
get angry so suck a embrace your
stereotypes like this guy right here
handsome and he's probably a
dummy he's short and insecure and he's
probably good with money oh you are good
with money do not have sexual relations
with students or teachers sir you hear
that that's you don't do it man I'd be
more I'd be more worried about Jonah
Hill doing it honestly cuz he's the one
who didn't get the girls in high school
right clearly I wasn't talking to you
big when I say shut the [__] up I'm
talking to
you cheers the new synthetic drug goes
by the street name HFS is this a a
drug Jessica will you go to prom with me
but I already know the answer it's
yes this is great where can I where can
I get this drug yeah exactly sign me up
I want to do this man this kid rules
ruled let me guess he passed away found
in his room no okay I don't want to do
it anymore jeno I enrolled you in a
bunch of [__] courses like
photography and drama since you were a
virgin through High School it says that
I just assumed
it here's your new identities all right
Brad and Doug McQuade Doug McQuade
that's so close to Total Recall Doug
Quaid Arnold Schwarzenegger's character
find the supplier first we don't have to
worry about the dealer God damn trate
the dealers find a supplier got it
sounds simple straight forward I'm sure
they'll do it on day one and we won't
have an entire film out of it hey Korean
Jesus I know we haven't made our first
arrest or maybe I'm not the best cop Ken
Jesus I just really don't want to [__]
this up sorry for swearing so much the
end I I don't really know how to end a
prayer the
end
that's great you two are staying at
Schmid's parents house for the duration
of this
assignment oh no oh God guys can we can
we get rid of this stuff I mean it looks
like I died in the car crash and you
guys haven't moved
on that's so great I look like Fred
Savage from The Wonder Years he he
really really does he does am I even
wearing underwear in this
picture um why I remember you know why
told it to a therapist about 8,000 times
oh my
God oh my God he really does look like
Fred Savage from the Wonder year yeah I
love Fred Savage so much he probably got
told that so many times as a kid yeah
and probably just put that into an
improv improv joke yeah you got to study
this stuff forget those identities
they're [__] you know back in the
day you were super popular and I wasn't
one man three balls I think that's
awesome that's great come on man we're
adults now we're best bu
it's definitely not going to happen
again I'm predicting Jonah Hill going to
get the beautiful woman for the prom I'm
calling it although that's kind of
creepy cuz he's much older now yeah you
say can and will be used against you int
of law you the right to an attorney you
cannot afford attorney one will be
appointed there you go you had it you
guys should have known this going to say
you should have known this way before
don't try hard at anything I do that
every day if anyone steps you on the
first day of school you punch them
directly in the face
five drive a kickass car I really fail
on all the other ones though oh they
went to the police impound sick dope
that's a sweet Camaro my guess is that
car was from the original TV show just
going to take a guess I have no idea but
awesome it's probably an Easter egg I
don't know yeah just guessing I have no
idea that is a cool ass car
[Music]
awesome
dude could barely handle his elbow just
getting a little nicked what dude
everybody's two straing just stay with
the one strap I can't I can't ride out
what are you doing what are you doing
don't suum to the peer pressure what are
you doing you're supposed to use two
straps strap is come to the pure
pressure the two St I love that so
much those are
nerds Dungeons and Dragons I don't know
I love it nerds are too strapping the
cool they look cool she's a one strapper
I'm so confused right
now you find the girl here Bri LS oh my
God she's in this Captain Captain Marvel
what oh my god um
okay hey Dave Franco love him whoa is
that your car yeah what's that thing at
10 miles to the gallon n try like s what
about you biod diesel dog we try to ride
bikes when we can Global crisis and what
not Noble hey hey y'all shut the hell up
trying to study he's
trying look at the nerd they're like the
cool call nerd man I'm sorry what
oh what turn that gay ass music off you
punch me because I'm gay what no I don't
think he's adapted to the times nope
you're way off buddy happen to turn out
to be gay afterwards I was gay when you
punched me it might have been homophobic
not to punch you just because you were
gay right you punched a little gay black
kid in the face is that Jake Johnson
girl guy you guys cross my line again
and you walk into this office I'm GNA
expel you which one of you is Doug do
they not know they
probably no dude I'm Brad okay good so
that means your name is Doug son oh my
God guys oh they really failed on their
prep work funny I wouldn't have taken
you for the brainy type I would but you
as a drama geek far less surprising
that's the easiest oh my God they get
the separate class
you go to my classes and I'm going to go
to yours okay now chemistry is the one
with the shapes and [__] right it
doesn't really matter if they fill out
the they're not there to stud they're
only there for like a minimum amount of
time right what's really sad about that
kid he was talented if he wasn't
talented it would be less sad that's not
I meant I was just pussing your balls
good I remember one time doing cocaine
with Willie Nelson's
horse you're talking about this in a
high school class this is awesome this
is the coolest teacher
a buddy of mine really wants it who who
would he call it's not so hard to
find
[Music]
the oh oh my favorite molecule is water
I'd marry it unless it was my daughter
it solid form floats on its liquid form
which makes it far outside the
norm givey Schmid H2O this H2 H2O H2 I'm
with you buddy H2
I'd say chlorophyll more like borophyll
what is your name Brad Brad wow look at
you Brad hey you remember just name this
time uh she's really attracted to him
what is it pop Quiznos it's a quiz on
the first person who finishes gets a $10
gift certificate to Quiznos
Quiznos we don't see those around
anymore we don't but they melt the
cheese in there I know that was
awesome good luck
oh my god oh wow teacher get back in
your corner it's okay because he's
technically older but if he weren't te
she doesn't know that what you doing
yeah because she doesn't know that
that's
creepy I've got
aw I'm just the cleverest okay yeah
maybe be a tree then me try one cooler
and faster and louder and better and
less in Secure H he's a great director
yeah okay those are great notes I'm just
going to I'm going to run outside and
I'm I'm going utilize those and I'm
going to come back it's such
[__] at least they're multiple
choice so he's got a decent he's got a
chance I bet you now he'll get n because
he guessed every one of them it didn't
even look you're fast not like that just
let me check you out check check my god
wow uh can I go take a dump we have this
hurry back rule so you're not back in 6
minutes I have to send you to the
principal 6
minutes oh my gosh damn she is laying it
on thick also too is 6 minutes enough
time to take a dump I don't know no
that's quite a
rule ah Dave Franco is the one in charge
of the drugs do you make this stuff or
look like a [__] scientist no just
sell it no I'm sorry I'm M just how many
you guys want I feel like this is not
going where we think it's going like
it's too easy maybe you're a narc you
know who calls people NCS narcs narc
narcs call people Nars and you call us
Nars and that's kind of call each
other time for this [__] you guys want
to do this or not I'm not selling to two
guys who just showed up with 30 days
left in school if if he's really a
dealer too take an hour get the out
drugs right here put in your moue and uh
there you go that's
it is it just a cookie you got to P the
trigger you got to P the trigger oh God
we got to throw up just think of
something gross think of something gross
you [__] think of something okay your
grandma's and there's going into
it no let's just finger each other's
mouths e yeah no you're not fingering my
mouth do you want to die okay fine let's
go come on come on you got to go deep
and quick
gross this is so dumb it's so dumb just
stick it in I don't know I've never done
this before stick it in
go oh my
God gross come on guys you got to reach
for the uula and then it goes out yeah
it's sometimes I have to do that when
I'm nauseous but I don't have another
individual do it for me I don't think I
want another individual there to try to
do it you guys are late now I'm going to
have to take you to the principal's
office take come on Doug McQuade you got
a lot of something special going on
there young man that's a what the hell
was that damn it son don't ever raise
your hand to me like that again all
right I consider that a
threat I'm Doug mcade you're the new kid
who's All County and track the track
star and his
Brad are the drugs taking hit yeah
right yeah
okay oh damn here's a deal my track team
is full of physically incapable rejects
I mean if I wasn't the coach I'd be
laughing my ass off at how [__] they
are oh God incapable
rejects I need you I've never had
tripped out before so it's crazy no I
would not want to hallucinate 4x400 at
today's track meet you do that and I'll
sign this
pass guys don't make me take you to the
principal's office do we have a deal yes
nice
a put your tongue back in your mouth e
your mouth and close it stop it actually
that's not bad e these teachers I was
going to say these are some of the
weirdest teachers yeah are you guys on
drugs
definitely not on drugs one particle of
onum has a nuclear reaction with a flux
capacitor carry the two chain did he
just get smart you know you got to take
drugs to be smart yeah
okay [__] you
science that's great I've got a
CR I'm just the cleverest F was ever my
fortune damn he remember those lines
really well
i' got a
crow not bad not
[Music]
bad keep it going keep it going that was
so tight no no no keep it going keep it
[Music]
going oh my God oh
God
what you
going don't throw the Baton you that's
literally me anytime it ask me to run
the mile in high school that was
brilliant yeah like how has he not been
thrown out yet both of them they're
clearly on drugs oh no stop come here
give her don't
make dude that was awesome how you
sabotaged that track me man organized
Sports were so fasion makes me sick so
you're out right he's getting cool you
should have just taken drugs the first
time in high school it would have been
so much cooler I really should have been
on drugs the entire time I was in high
school probably would have been more fun
lead dealer Eric Molson he's getting
into Berkeley early ad Mish who put this
together are you artistic it is Artistic
sir
[Laughter]
because cut the [__] I want to know
who's the supply we don't know that's
why there's a question mark on his face
oh I think it's the gym teacher oh cuz
he wasn't reacting to anything that they
were doing I don't know why I think it's
him you might be right you two standing
around finger popping each other's
[__] we're not finger popping each
other's ass house well he's like put
your tongue back in your mouth and all
that that's why it just feel like he was
protecting his investment right I mean
we also so when he raised his hand he
got really defensive like okay I think
you might be right and me thinking back
on these teachers are very
nefarious yes what are you doing in here
I'm here to to study I know everything
really what's a coent bond [__] you man
I don't need to tell you I I wasn't
trying to be rude sorry I love that kid
he's so nice yeah what are you doing
with all those phones anyway crack and
jail break kids phones uh try and save
for college I can't install a spyware to
remotely monitor calls wait you can't do
it no I
can't is he being sarcastic absolutely
we just have to do something wildly
irresponsible to earn their trust you
saying we should throw a party and then
Molly will invite Eric and that'll be
the quickest way for me to bro down with
her you get in with the nerd kids and
see what's going on over there sure his
parents will be totally cool with him
having a party there I just call him cuz
we're co-staring this play together and
hello M get off the
phone I love you honey douge Doug
Douglas so serious right
now that's such a relatable thing
actually I'm having a party this is so
you and Eric and Warrior
whatever posting on Facebook okay yeah
yeah oh my God all right I'll see you
SCH here great person oh byebye bye bye
what the [__]
you how are we going to buy alcohol dude
I don't have a fake
idea huh they they couldn't call
mcloven
got ice cream in there that's awesome
that's cool I've never had a punch where
they put ice cream in it we need to do
that some it tastes like we have to do
it pound what is this movie pound of
marijuana best party ever
Bingo who invited you guys love it I did
we love them heck yeah do we have enough
chips is this playlist too like Dancy
feels too D it's pretty Dancy it's so
nerve-wracking having a party at your
house cuz the biggest fear is like
what's getting destroyed yeah and and
what are people going
through oh he just jacked his phone
yeah see aside the this thing that's a
great line yeah this is my parents
bedroom oh no are they going
in
oh there's the nudity wow
you never know if you might run into
that at a party I guess not thank you
for the hospitality but we got to get
going you know how it is yeah is it
ready or not read this please wait
extracting data from [__] off it's a
bust no you can just delay him come on
turn on a better song who the hell is
this yeah who's this guy partying with
some new stuff want to know you hook up
some me my boys to get in on it got
other commitments on that front so take
five take five let me get this I got
this is he going to just punch him let's
do it man man come on what's your
real okay what do I do hit him oh damn
oh no
no use your words
your [__] my [__]
this all right oh
[__] yeah you did
it that was a good distraction yeah oh
perfect right in the
pocket
what when did I get
stabbed that's awesome
yeah that's great the adrenaline was
running so deep he didn't know hope when
I get stabbed I'm like that's awesome
yeah blow it out blow
oh go all right all right at least it's
an antiseptic
okay oh my God these kids are like this
nerd is getting getting some action this
is the coolest part oh no they're
passing around the drugs oh everybody's
getting going to get wild it's not good
though that mean some kid could
something could happen at the party die
uhoh get my I said out the part
over she have a stick in her hand I love
it that's great all how you feel about
making a little extra money whatever it
is I'm in yes now we're in I can't sell
all this [__] on my own but I only bring
in people I like I introduce you to my
hookup how's that sound let's do it no
you hey thank you again for the party
man you you oh he's jealous yep dude
this is part the tables have turned it's
part of the plan but like he thought
he'd be like there was no way he could
get cool what kind of a sick animal
draws an
ejaculating into an 8-year-old's mouth
like an airplane throwing up you think I
don't know that balls I know all about
balls I Robert Dy Jr before he got sober
when he was really [__] up
I took Eric's phone and I had Zach put
his monitoring device in it I don't know
if that was a good idea this is like the
smartest move I've ever pulled so I'm
sorry what are you getting mad at me for
is he getting too deep he's getting
emotionally compromised I feel like he
wants to stay in high school longer and
not figure it out because he finally now
knows how it is to be cool yeah that's a
that's a good point right he's like is
getting emotionally compromised at the
situation
totally password kneel before Zod you
may enter kneel before Zod that's
amazing do you understand the reference
to Superman 2 oh cool KN before zard I
don't know I don't believe in possession
ja feel ja feel definitely feel yeah
Smitty oh
no I'll be right don't blow your cover
she's
gonna oh no go to her and send her out
and be like that's my crazy grandma I
have got to call Annie she is going to
die sh shut shut your [__]
mouth shut your [__] mouth I will
straight up punch you in the face if you
not
[Laughter]
your oh who she's TR to grab my J she
was like oh my God I have arthritis
hurts my hand I need to grab a handful
of that I was like get the [__] off wow
I have arthritis what a possessively
sick woman and I need to grab a handful
of why would she try doing that with a
teenage young man and also she has
arthritis it's going to be really hard
to hold on to that dick that's
disgusting that you would do
[Music]
that at least he sticks to his
environmentalism yeah sings it in a
song Ready notore oh he's going to
listen into his phone and Jonah Hill's
going to say something bad about his
partner a long time what are you doing I
heard something I just just want to make
sure that you and Eric are going to be
careful with it would just suck if
something bad happened cuz I already
lost my dad to act
together see Neil before thought that's
Terren stamp okay we going to take the
prom there's no one to go prom with us
pull up in a white stallion of a limo
you got fine ass Honeys with you you're
dressed to the nines with your best buds
dubs fly out behind you slow motion he
never got to go to prom and he's going
to get to go with his best buddies or he
could take that teacher that really
likes him right oh God I hope not isn't
aren't you and Eric wouldn't you and
Eric go together not that I know
of ask
her oh he's got
PTSD but this is a different situation I
know but it's come on
maybe oh my God are you okay I am that
is the actual sound of
joking I was wondering if you uh say it
come on maybe you want to go with me to
prom you want to go to Me Maybe with me
to prom Yes W we made it good for you
Doug oh are they going to kiss
somebody's going to interrupt of course
it's the movie trible there man just put
it what what putting
it there maybe because he's a rule
follower and is like you're not allowed
to right sleep with or like students and
your brother aren't related right cuz
you look totally different he's adopted
we all suspect from a very lame family
yeah I know it you called that yeah
tools he hangs out you know how Tom Cruz
is always pissed off at Rainman that's
like my life oh boy do you understand
that reference yeah it's it's an old
school one and it's calling him yeah
that's not that's not cool yeah you
either find a supplier or I'm going jump
your asses off Street I heard Eric
talking on the phone yesterday about
meeting up with a stuffed Piñata is that
a call for sex that was an email he was
about to click before Brie Larson walked
in on him yeah it said pinata yeah how
do I look ravishing is it too sexy of an
outfit yeah yeah definitely definitely
I'm so happy that I met you you're like
the only guy that I can really trust
yeah boy that's going to suck for her
when she finds out known as Sal Peter
God
oh the pinata oh that's where the drugs
are coming in I need to borrow you now
it's not a good time it's a really good
time cuz my pinata is killing me is that
good for a thing I have a feeling
there's nothing in it but we'll see feel
like it's got to be right there's got to
okay oh they're going to go in and Chase
oh no oh God you're going to miss the
play you shouldn't have taken that part
when he's under
cover what no oh cuz they have so many
violations because they keep parking in
handicap why are they doing that
driver's car school bus I'm driving no
you're not I never get to drive oh are
they taking the Ed car oh I wanted them
to take the school
bus
go guys hey wait guys you're not on the
list hey guys wait who
cares like it's a crap car and a crap
job anyways I don't give a shnit shnit
it's a new word Andrew Flash Gordon just
made up are these the biker they wanted
to arest him for the marijuana before
those are the guys in the park that's
just too
crazy we think in that thing oh it has
to be in there or maybe they just want
to play with a pinata they're taking to
a kid's barbecue over the weekend you
sure wor I see guys we definitely got to
follow him and find out though there is
no way he's making it back to the play
no no just pretend like you're sucking
my why am I automatically
you that's a very inconspicuous vehicle
a student driver take your foot off the
brake no take your foot off The Brak
no
guys
you're okay now we've done it you not
driving mother
get I mean at least then you could just
be like sorry student driver
easy easy easy my
God
[Music]
whoa
oh I know but the whole point was to
follow them oh god well now they're
going to get chased after yeah but they
need to follow them to their place it's
two people back
there sh oh no traffic oh
God oh [__] what's wrong with you run I
can't I'm wearing tights I got skinny
chees on the
same get out the car douche to call here
jackass oh my God yeah all right sorry
buddy hope somebody picks you up later
there's golf balls in this what am I
supposed to do with this no that's
awesome
oh that's great nice hit woow uhoh
[Music]
okay oh damn big boom
coming what happened I don't know it
just didn't explode who do you guys
think you're in a movie
[Music]
mhm right there no testing yes you are
you're texed no I'm
not fair I'll be there fairly I'm
driving why you always drip over the
like that did you say fairly like a
fairy fairy like well like Tinker Bell
right you are fine and [__] don't worry
oh my
God that was a very attractive woman not
going to
lie I'm loving all these vehicles
they're
getting oh they're in a a Volkswagen I
love that good old bug bug 1963 bug and
bright orange was my first vehicle
you're
[Music]
welcome oh no that's got to
oh
ow that's got to hurt dude he just got
ran over by an 18wheeler oh my God
Windows what is it not going to explode
again no there's fire right next to it
cuz the bike
right it's going against action movie
tropes I love it I love
it the hell oh my God she had a gun okay
hey
girl oh oh
[Music]
boyi sounded like the willhelm screen oh
no not the chickens not the chickens why
did that one have to blow up seriously
come on
movie
I don't know how long this case is going
to last and Eric's going to get into
Berkeley and honestly I can get in too
who knows I could ride this thing out I
could be a doctor or something have you
lost your
mind this is not real buddy I could be a
doctor boys squads come quickly hey
wor I'm here uh I know I missed uh first
few scenes I want to thank give it up to
uh oh my
goodness we just R right into this thing
huh
this is my twin
together it's okay I'll make it up to
you and uh let's
fly I guess I should do something I
should probably not just stand here
watching I should take
action best friend ever this is
definitely more entertaining than not
you
don't yeah I'm sorry I don't want to
talk to you ever again she's definitely
not going to prom now you stupid
[Applause]
idiot come
come damn he's strong to withstand a
rock stop stop it you're expelled both
of you are expelled and that's the end
of act
two Bravo that was amazing I want to
know how long they rehears that yeah
beautifully choreographed is that it
you're not going to you're not going to
scream at
us
nope I'm going just fire you oh I mean
the fact that these guys got through
three cases and they haven't even
finished
one kind of says something you know
what's crazy to me is that I think that
I actually thought that we were brothers
I would have taken a bullet for you a
get in now both of
you is this the reveal of the dealer
yeah is he going to be like are these
the two guys you saw or something the
messed up [__] went down yesterday yeah
after we made the exchange our potential
business partners got followed by some
cops okay a lot of things have made me
wonder about you the taste of Music fact
that you look like a 40-year-old
man I
realized there's no way you guys could
be cops no way no way I got this deal
going down the supplier is going to be
there I need people I can trust hey come
on okay right over here we're going to
shoot these bottles we're going to
practice okay oh God don't be
good definitely not cops that was
actually really awesome beginner's luck
we played a lot of Area 51 in Time
Crisis we're good any predictions on the
dealer I'm still going to stick with my
original I do like your guess I'm just
going to stick with the gym the gym
[Music]
teacher I mean cuz I got to assume it's
someone we've seen before they're not
just going to give us someone random and
I don't know who else it could be
besides him doing our time chores right
now if you stay in this house you have
time for
[Music]
chores
yes what if it's like the Nerds I don't
think it is cuz they don't but what if
they're just like we sell it but we
don't do them the nerd the Nerds that
he's gotten to be friend I don't think
it is I don't know man that definitely
be a Twist if it was the Nerds I will
say I would not have seen that coming in
anyway
there a there's actually an emotional
core to this film I mean it's not like
deep or anything but there's an
emotional core yeah their chemistry is
great oh they're they're really good
together you can really feel will you go
to prom with
me that's
sweet go oh they both missed their prom
their first prom
are we really going to take down a whole
drug operation by ourselves I got some
contacts that'll help us the Nerds yeah
if it's the Nerds I don't know if they
would let them help them get into prom
right no I think it was a bad that's
like all bad what I guessed I think it's
totally wrong um that is great that's
great I love that
nice oh my God that's the lady
from that's awwesome
that's the worker lady that was in
that's friends with them as cops she was
constantly being questioned cuz she's a
you need to leave need to leave need to
get out of here right now making a lot
of hand gestures okay my name is not
Doug it's Schmidt and I'm a cop what
this is not the time to display this
information pay no attention to the
couple kissing in the background it is
him you're all
right beautiful bread I just didn't know
who else it would be no yeah it's a
great yeah of course he loves his
Doritos I do agree with the finger and
the well yeah he was just trying to hide
that's what told me he was trying to
make like it was obvious to him they
were on drugs and he even said it and
he's like Noe put put your tongue back
that back in there so nobody
knows oh no oh they're going to know who
they are y damn it oh boy here in
trouble now of all the guys yeah what
you having a party now who these two
mother oh crap hey kid come here you you
look
familiar I was in a a french fry
commercial when I was a kid do I look
like I eat french fries I don't know you
look like you're in great shape but
maybe you have like one cheet like a
carb car blow
[Laughter]
out you look like you're
a yeah theme song's like come to
Andrew's
fren I love it
that's my
song who wants a piece dog or whatever
your name is you lied to
me
oh phase five is where you get overly
honest right I know these too your boys
are
cops you are outgunned we party together
man you brought us Taco Bell you made me
this friendship bracelet well he's not
really your friend he was pretending the
whole time Taco Bell bring somebody Taco
Bell is like giving a blood sacrifice
yo don't hit de Franco I know these guys
were
C there you
are drop your guns or I'll spray your
brains all over the
room drop the guns or she's dead she
looks dead already what
shoot yeah I can hear her breathing she
just passed out from the drugs we're
good dude it's just like the image with
the guy and the woman and the woman like
boom boom boom between
this is his character Arc to hit the the
moving Target let's let's just relax and
we can all leave here as friends yeah
let's do that you all boys are stup
we're going to
die God damn it he's undercover to on
your knees Johnny Depp Johnny
Jeff Johnny de oh my
goodness little dweebs just r a 5-year
investigation we had no idea hey the
original crew you play saxophone in my
sister's wedding man T too hey that's
the best twist ever Metro Police Jump
Street division that's funny because we
were actually Jump Street
what
what oh
whoa oh no not the original crew here
take the money all right we're getting
out of
here you could him just behind his head
not aiming anywhere best cop ever
sometimes I was a jerk we were
undercover I just I didn't feel good
about myself that's it's like basically
what they would say to each other the
tight pants was just so that people
would think I'm cool he called him Doug
they have the same names as their
undercover names that I ever needed was
my best friend let's do this let's make
a baby what are you talking I don't know
try close
[Music]
sorry yes get your slow-mo action shot
yeah
you oh
yeah whoa
cool he's gonna throw it oh God so that
would actually really hurt
[Music]
nice shot that was crazy you killed a
guy hey they threw up finally
right it's the song at every graduation
right
yeah I just remember this song from
Scary Movie too
[Music]
hey h that's like
perfect
[Music]
look who I did that was that was
beautifully perfect that was great
perfect slide Perfect Landing come hang
out with me
back give me my
money oh damn I'm living my dream of
standing in a
LMO oh my
God what what K you kill
you no oh my God oh my gosh girl you got
to relax how drunk is she how how do you
not see the gunshots hear the gunshots
I'm to oh my god oh you had to go you
you wouldn't lay off it that well that's
probably the safer thing too you are too
aggressive you still got those shotgun
shells yeah pop Quiznos now they'll
finally have he going to do what he
learned from chemistry yeah that would
be a coent Bond brother that's coent
Bond see I knew that was going to come
back to play that makes them stick
together are you saying we're coent
bonds yes and that you did call that one
[Music]
too but it's going to be delayed what's
this tequila I don't know it's it was
supposed to
explode using that big old brain love
it where' you learn how to do that man
chemistry chemistry [__] it's a good
thing they actually switched yes and
thank goodness for your nerd friends who
actually taught you a lot about that
don't you pull that armor nope oh come
on let's go this is your test he no no
no I said
no oh my gosh I didn't mean to shoot you
I meant to shoot him are you Al buddy
okay took a pull for me man do you have
a vest on yeah but he still got in the
shoulder the vest doesn't cover the
shoulder that's skin
head
shot right in the eye right between the
eyes we want I know but in the in the
poster he got him in both the eyes you
peaked in high school mother Ah that's a
good line oh oh
yeah
oh yikes that reminds me of Robocop oh
boy yikes you are under arrest anything
you said can and will be us that's a
great call back
yes yes Miranda writes B that's a great
great call back look I'm sorry I called
you Rainman I know I didn't say you were
but you're smart that's a compliment
he's smart and he won an
Oscar
yeah hey that was a jump and it was on
the street they just got to do it 20
more times yeah that's not funny is that
it what
it's on the ground
no oh my God
no no no
[Music]
no no I hated it gross I'm really sorry
I know you wanted a guy to trust and I
wanted to be that person so badly you
deserve a guy who who Who's good and who
doesn't lie to you thanks for saving my
life a put her there partner
feel like she's going to kiss him yeah
okay good call felt that coming again if
she wasn't 18 I'd be creeped out yeah
on I had a feeling they were going to
end up together since you two Cowboys
love to drink booze smoke weed with kids
and anything with a big ass in jeans
I'mma send you to a place where all that
[__] is allowed oh I love Disneyland you
two sons of [__] are going to college
oh no is it going to be Berkeley though
is that the sequel I want to see that
whoa that was an awesome mening credit
Miller yes that was dope oh my God that
was so fun that was a lot of fun oh I
didn't know Jonah Hill did the story
that's awesome that's like oh and these
ending like these what this these ending
credits are awesome yeah uh that was a
blast I had from the past I had a lot of
fun the the chemistry between the two of
them like casting 10 Stars off the
charts because if it wasn't them two it
wouldn't have been as good with their
chemistry um so good and I love the
heartfelt moments like when he when he
hears Jonah Hill speaking about like
he's like a Rainman he annoys me he's
like not smart whatever and you see like
Channing Tatum right before that being
like like good job man like you made the
move you asked her to prom like he was
always really supportive of him and then
that must have been really heartbreaking
right and then the way that they come
back together I mean Bravo I always
complain I would complain if this is
like a funny funny movie with lots of
action if it didn't have the heart I'd
be like I'm not sold on it it does have
the heart and I thank you oh he did do
the teacher oh boy I can't imagine why
was she giving him signed she wanted him
like at all oh Mark mothers Boro the the
composer that was the composer of Thor
uh Ragnarok which I I love his score in
th ref one of my favorite scores I I I
agree with everything you just said like
yeah the the comedy and the action were
all there but it was the heart and the
the chemistry between the two of them
that was you know that sold me and made
me love this movie so much and it was
just so much fun uh I'm sure there was
10 obviously we did not watch the 21
Jump Street TV show with uh Johnny Depp
and Richard Grio though that was such a
cool thing to I don't again I don't know
I mean maybe we'll see here in the creds
in a second I obviously we know that was
Johnny Depp I don't know if that was
Richard GCO at the end or who who that
actor was but um that was such a cool
little uh Easter egg if you will at the
end there um because I did not see that
coming um and then also too with I
assume the car and I'm sure there were
plenty other Easter eggs that they did
for people who had seen the show
um but yeah no I mean I thought it was
interesting too like cuz obviously Jonah
Hill's character Schmid I believe his
name was he was you know more on the
nerdy side when he was in high school
and you know awkward and just uh wasn't
cool and obviously uh Chan Tatum excuse
me uh was uh cool but not smart and you
know they had their character arcs kind
of like got infused with okay you know J
Jonah Hill got to learn how to you know
well he got to be cool when he went back
to high school all never been kiss style
you know Drew Barrymore if you will um
but then he felt like what it felt uh
you know when he made fun of him it's
like oh this is what it feels like yeah
like yeah it's cool but it's more
important like friendship and
Brotherhood is more important and then
also two on the flip side um I think
chaining Tatum also realized like yeah
it's not like being cool isn't like what
it's all about and like using your brain
and other things like Brotherhood again
same same kind of thing like they just
met in the middle uh there's more
important things out in the world but I
love that uh he got to use his brain in
such a unique way like from the
chemistry class learning and turning
that into like an explo or a bomb
whatever he uh the convenient Bond
or thank you yes clearly she's much
smarter than me um but yes um that was I
I really love that touch of the film but
yeah there was just a lot more layers
than I was expecting it wasn't super
not was trying to be or anything but
it's also like when what you were just
saying of like him getting smart was
like let alone from the kids that he
never would have spoken to back in the
day right that was also in his flip
absolutely but also too it was about
like adapting to the times because I
mean Jonah Hill even said yeah damn if I
would have just went to high school 10
years later I missed it by a decade like
it's like because I mean we saw on the
first scene when they went back when
they got back to high school like he hit
the kid he's like yeah he's listening to
this game music it's like dude you're
you're in a different time you're you're
in the wrong time like maybe 10 15 years
ago wrong time zone yeah that would have
been okay but like that doesn't that
doesn't work now but it was funie
wouldn't necessarily work in 2023 no way
there's there's a lot of stuff that they
wouldn't wouldn't pass if they made this
film today but um yeah I mean it it was
a lot of fun I do I do like the the flip
of like you know him getting cool and
him getting smart and learning because
before it was like Channing Tatum's
character was all about like I have to
act like I don't care and if you don't
care then you're cool and all he had to
do was like care a little bit and then
he realized like he could tap into
everything that he had been put in kind
of in the in the back burner which is
his brains um and I I really like the
Nerds I'm like I want oh they were great
as friends they were great no I mean I I
wouldn't have expected Channing Tatum to
go with that crew but again adapting and
changing to the times it actually was
perfect it Mak sense for him to be with
those crew CU he had so much fun
together yeah no they were great I I
loved that crew and then uh just again
they were unique to him and he was
unique to them so I think oh Superman 2
that was so good the Neo before Zod has
the greatest P besides have you seen Ace
Ventura Pet Detective yes but it's been
ages so I will add this to my second uh
favorite password cuz my first one is
from Ace Pet Detective when he says
what's the password New England clam
chout now it's going to be Neil before
Zod so I've got two passwords now but
look at him I know yes yes your phone
show yeah exactly New England wow this
is long
clam uh sh my nerdy side showing my
referencing nerdy side but really really
are no but um there were just so many
different great uh aspects of this film
um also to the the whole uh thing with
um
with the uh with theand oh no no oh they
had the Miranda Right call back was that
call back I loved yeah I love to the
idea just I mean the way they play with
fun action adventure Oh I thought they
were showing in after credit scene the
idea too of just playing with fun action
adventure tropes they did it in a couple
different ways like when they were on
one of the when they were on the one of
those chases when he was in the Peter
pant tights and so they're like waiting
for explosions like oh here comes an
explosion
oh here comes an expion no explosion
then they're jumping over the uh what is
it the the limo like to make it look
cool when you jump over the hood of the
car to get to the front how did that
look perfectly cuz that that's that's an
action adventure thing and then jumping
over the couch and Jonah Hill couldn't
land it it's just I love the way they
were playing with action adventure
tropes it was just it was hysterical
like it made sense for the story but it
was hysterical at the same point uh but
yeah and then there was obviously the
the story story line that they were
doing with the the drugs and all that at
first I thought that they were going to
um the first scene they had where Dave
Franco was selling them drugs I thought
it was just going to be like um he was
just going to sell it was just going to
be like a normal cooking and like oh wow
this was a waste of time but that's what
I thought they were going with that I
mean obviously we knew there were drugs
involved but I thought that's where they
were going at first and then it was
going to at oh he had to earn their
trust or something but I'm like all
right you're just selling this to two
guys who 30 days left in school who just
showed up in your school like you're
very trustworthy sir right but uh I mean
I guess on the flip side like for his
argument is like he's just making them
eat it right now he's not letting them
take it anywhere but still I was like
this is very trustworth yeah and I I
like the setup how it's is it Tarantino
or an Edgar right thing where it's like
the titles pop up so I feel like we
needed them to do the drug so we could
get through the phases and see them
again so that when we would see others
we're like oh yeah they're at they're at
Phase phase four or phase five um I
liked how those came up the phase one
phase two phase three it was really
really fun to see them go through that
um and man just like take me back to
that party yo so I can like actually uh
be in a real high school party [__]
except like we don't break anything it
just seemed fun and I won't do any drugs
but I will drink yeah but when he gets
stabed and doesn't really because the
adrenaline stabbed yeah but the
adrenaline was pumping so much for him
because he was
he's never been a cool kid he's I mean
he's never been in a f well I mean he's
I know he's been in police train but
he's never actually a real one yeah not
a he got he got pum pummeled over by
that one guy in the biker but he's never
actually been in a fight and just like
again had his adrenaline rushing so much
well I guess you could say he had his
adrenaline rushing once when he tried
asking that one woman to prom in the
first scene of the film um but clearly
you could tell she was uh very
disinterested uh but again he didn't
have a knife in the back of his uh or in
his back or whatever that yeah so um but
I just I love everyone's reaction to it
and then they just poured alcohol on the
wound it's like go back to partying and
like oh my God yeah it's a party I would
love to attend so good and I loved when
they finally when he asked him to go to
prom I was like yes this movie The
Writing I love the story and the writing
I thought it was just like it was really
really good uh I five five out of five
man for the writing cuz it made me laugh
Oh I thought you about to say five out
of 10 I was like I love the writing five
out of 10 five out of five 10 out of 10
for the writing cuz I I really loved it
I thought it was really really funny I
thought the the pacing the tone was
great and also just like the the pacing
of the editing even though they didn't
use um like any crazy techniques of
shots I mean most of it was just basic
setup of like a master and a and a mid
shot and a closeup right for a lot of
times when he's there with a cop and
whatnot they got more creative when when
they're in the action but a lot of that
even was just like slow-mo like it's not
like you were doing anything crazy
cinematically and this movie it didn't
even like cross my mind that I was like
oh this is just like basic setups it it
is that with some other playful stuff
because the script in the story and also
the chemistry with the actors you don't
need it like this is just it's great and
even though the the film was paced
really like I it was kind of a fanatic
pce but it was still paced really well
but I still like that they took their
time progressing the two of them with
their Brotherhood it never felt rushed
it always felt organic to me like by the
time that they there was a mutual like
understanding and Brotherhood yeah it
felt earned it didn't feel like wow that
was really quick I mean I'm still glad
that they ended up to like you know
having a mutual understanding and their
brothers and all that or their great
friends Partners whatever you want to
say but like yeah but that happened so
quickly like I don't buy no they really
took their time in this film and like it
was close to the end of the film but
again it was it was really well earned
and I bought it and like everything they
had been through throughout the film
everything they had done for each other
I really did buy that he would jump even
though he he did have a bulletproof vest
on him it didn't matter like there's
still parts of your body that are still
exposed you still got your face too that
could get hit I really do buy that he
would jump in front of a bullet for him
you know that was that was hard and I
loved how the how the climax of their
fight was actually during the Peter Pan
play and The Way They Carried that out
of course it has to come out of like I
heard what you called me and like you
know he was just calling him your sish
your whatever they were saying it was
like that big fight happened on a stage
in front of a bunch of people I liked
how that all came out and I do agree the
ending was totally earin because they
took their time it's great I I love I
really like this movie I thought it was
a blaster Ro so I don't know I'm going
to go like eight eight and a half out of
10 cuz I'm just like what a what a blast
this was okay we got to be like Jonah
Hill and Channing Tatum on this I'm
going to go eight and a half out of 10
this look at us we did it any last words
before we get out of here just uh I
really enjoy this I think you said it
best uh the the action was great it was
fun uh the comedy it was hysterical but
it had the heart and the chemistry
between the two of them was fantastic I
uh I can't think of a better Duo for
this um I'm always going to be curious
even though it's never it probably never
going to happen um cuz they had talked
about for a long time with Sony uh they
wanted to do a team up of Men In Black
and 21 drum Street yeah oh what why
didn't they do that I don't know that
would have worked um I mean I still
would have seen me after this movie I
mean like if they yeah I I'm interested
to see the sequels of this specifically
I want to see 22 Jump Street but I mean
I'm just cuz I remember when they were
talking about 21 Jump Street black but
I'm curious how that would have worked
yeah I mean if you have a good story
it's a good story but that's an
interesting pairing of dumla that I
never would have thought of well I guess
we'll see interest well it's not it's
most likely I it was talked about years
and years and years ago but uh I don't
know if that's ever going to happen
whatever I think the bigger UPS y all
should make it that's all for us we love
you so much don't forget to leave a like
leave a comment tell us how cool we are
because we love so much not and we will
see you very very soon on the next one
[Music]
bye